hey youtubers it's Charlie so their
early reports coming in from Captain
America Civil War and people are
describing it as a horror film and that
just makes me so excited to see it
imagine a Marvel horror film I would
think that Doctor Strange could get
close to horror it's being directed by a
director that does horror films but what
does an Avengers horror film look like
most of the Civil War talk is about the
last half hour being this emotional
horror marathon in the fight between
Captain America and Iron Man just
because as you're sitting in your seat
as an audience member you should have a
hard time deciding who's right most of
you have probably already decided
whether you're teamcap or teamironman
just based on who your favorite
character is but a really good story and
really compelling characters should be
able to change your mind so even if
you've read comic books Civil War and
your team cap don't be surprised if you
walk away thinking team Iron Man and if
you go with a group of friends you can
make the person who cries first pay for
drinks that night there'll be a whole
lot of crying but the producers and the
actors have been saying a lot of funny
stuff from behind the scenes as well as
info about how they drew battle lines
like how they picked which characters
would go on which team so here we go
number one obviously the Winter Soldier
is gonna be team cap cap is trying to
prevent him from being arrested by the
anti-terrorist coalition number two the
Falcon had also become a good friend of
caps since Winter Soldier so he's gonna
be team cap and since Bucky and Falcon
have the closest relationship to Captain
America they referred to them as caps
girlfriends on set and I'm talking about
the other actors and the producers just
like hey how's your girlfriend Falcon
doin as your other girlfriend Bucky
doing speaking which number three Sharon
Carter who I don't actually know if
she'll be caps girlfriend or not they
had the relationship in the comics that
cap never got to have with Peggy Carter
but all she really said about her
character in the film is that she's
willing to go the distance for cap so
I'm guessing she's gonna try and pull a
fast one with black widow because Black
Widow is gonna be team Iron Man and when
most of the actors talk about their
characters making hard choices it
usually means going against their
friends so if she's willing to go the
distance for cap she's probably gonna
have to do something dirty to Black
Widow suddenly this video seems like
it's gotten more sexual than I intended
it to be number four cap has kind of
been a tutor for Scarlet Witch who still
has absolutely no idea what the
limitations of her powers are they're
not really doing her chaos magic from
the comics
because dr. strange is bringing magic
into the Marvel Universe so I guess
they're linking her powers to the mind
gem which is how Baron von Strucker
brought her powers out with her brothers
powers will probably see some iconic
Scarlet Witch comic book moments but the
MCU version of the character doesn't
carry around quite as much baggage as
the comic book version of Scarlet Witch
but on a team Iron Man number 5 probably
the biggest WTF is Black Widow who's
been caps partner for a long time going
team Iron Man ScarJo mostly said that it
has to do with Winter Soldier Winter
Soldier is the reason she goes team Iron
Man she's still very wary of what they
call the man as in people like
Thunderbolt Ross but her concerns over
Winter Soldier outweigh her hatred of
the man number 6 war machine obviously
gonna be team Iron Man they've been
friends for a long time his suit was
adapted from one of Iron Man's other
suits and because the whole idea of
government oversight is such a big deal
in the movie war machine is already a
tool for the government because he works
for the military
vision is a bit of a question mark as to
why he chooses team Iron Man but I think
it just has to do with the idea of
oversight he probably likes the idea
that someone is watching The Watchmen
number 7 black panther probably chooses
team Iron Man because he's all for
government oversight of the Avengers
he's from an international country the
Avengers have largely been an American
organization so it makes sense that he
would want the Avengers to take a more
international approach and that would
require international oversight but I
actually just realized I forgot Hawkeye
and ant-man so number 8 moving back to
team cap Hawkeye probably chooses team
cap because he was kind of in a similar
situation in the first Avengers film
remember he went bad like the Winter
Soldier was turned by Loki but they
saved him brought him back they could
have totally locked him up and thrown
away the key
so when faced with the same choice when
cap cheeses to save his friend just like
The Avengers chose to save Hawkeye he
probably thinks that Iron Man who wants
to bring him in is wrong number 9 one of
the more fun members ant-man
total Captain America fangirl there's
actually this scene there's supposed to
be this scene in the movie where he
touches Captain America's peck just like
Peggy Carter did after he first came out
of the super-soldier program is going to
be so great but battle lines are going
to be drawn before number 10 the big man
of the hour spider-man shows up so I'm
gonna read Marvel's official synopsis
for the movie this will give you an idea
for when spider-man's going to show up
after another
International incident involving the
Avengers results in collateral damage
political pressure mounts to install a
system of accountability in a governing
body to determine when to enlist the
services of the team as then went to
role the Avengers out when to call a
code GREEN
the new status quo fractures the
Avengers while they tried to protect the
world from a new and nefarious villain
it sounds like when the movie opens up
the new Avengers team with with the new
members of the team are gonna be rolling
around cleaning stuff up there's this
big crossbones action scene that's
supposed to happen early in the film
that's like the whole first hour of the
film some goes down then
Thunderbolt Ross comes in with the
sokovia accords battle lines get drawn
and then for like the last half of the
film they're going at each other so I'm
guessing we won't see spider-man 2 like
the last third of the film we don't
actually have an official runtime so I
can't say the movies gonna be two and a
half hours we'll see him in the last 45
minutes or something like that once we
know how long the movie is exactly we
can guess when he's gonna show up but it
will probably be after the halfway point
what about the new nefarious villain
it can't be crossbones because he's
supposed to show up pretty early in the
film
I'm guessing it's Daniel Bruhl scare
achter and I know people are still
wondering if it's Baron Zemo I've heard
reports that Baron Zemo isn't in the
film I've heard reports that he is so
we'll just have to wait and see but
there will be a villain that's bigger
than Captain America and Iron Man
they'll be each other's antagonist for
most of the film and that's really where
you get to that horror through line
Avengers tearing other Avengers apart I
can't wait to go into the movie theater
and hear people screaming leave him
alone leave our man alone stop hitting
him
it's gonna be so great and I haven't
seen that film myself but people are
saying that it's testing really well
that just means that everyone loves it
Batman V Superman has also been testing
really well recently so we're gonna get
a whole lot of superheroes ripping other
superheroes apart but let me know in the
comments which fight are you more
excited to see Captain America fighting
Iron Man or Batman fighting Superman the
huge difference between them though is
that the end of Captain America Civil
War is probably not going to feel very
hopeful you're probably gonna be crying
your eyes out the end of that man be a
Superman I think is gonna be more
optimistic because they're building into
Justice League while you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
to learn what's going on with the
Deadpool sequel and you can click here
for the zoom
last video that I just posted thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you